foreign
is with us in Atlantic City New Jersey
hi Kelly how are you
I'm doing great I'm so excited to talk
to you you too what's up
okay so I am 53 years old I am a
kindergarten teacher
and
um I got remarried my second marriage
five years ago and when I did that I
moved into my husband's home
and I was very very attached to my
family home that I had raised my
children so I kept it and I rented it
and
um my first four years I had a military
family they were fantastic I loved them
they were wonderful and they got
transferred so they left and I took a
new family who stopped saying me
they wait a minute they stopped paying
you
yeah these stocks paid they did not pay
June rent and then they didn't pay July
and now they're not paying August
why
um because they're scumbags why are you
tolerating
well that's why I'm calling you so what
happened so what I've done so far is I
um I went back with my realtor and
um I started the process uh I sent them
the nudists
um with the full balance owed you know
gave a little weeks of Hyatt and then if
not the notifying them that I was
beginning the eviction process
um they're guiding me along I just know
that you are the expert on it so that's
why I called you
um
when did the election when does the
eviction notice go out
well yeah I'm kidding they got the
letter yesterday stating what they owed
and and Advising them they had a week to
pay for the eviction process starts okay
so a week from today the eviction
process starts correct correct
um so I just want to tell you this
really quick because it's very important
to me
um
I told you I had that was my family home
where I raise my children and when I was
39 years old I had been married for 18
years
and my husband came home and he had a
girlfriend and he walked out the door
like that
and when our divorce was finalized I was
upside down on that house fifty thousand
dollars I had not a dime
and he paid me a monthly amount which he
paid Faithfully
and from that
I now have a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in mutual funds I have a pension
I have a job I have um
my house is worth 300 I owe 200. so I
really turned it around yeah you did
that's impressive
yeah I did good for you good yes and so
this is very emotional for me
um my ex-husband
um and I became good friends who were
fed out we raised our children
three years ago he had a heart attack
and died
he left my daughter's money
they are they're young 24 25 years old
and my daughter wants to buy that house
she wasn't ready yet she was finishing
college she I didn't want to rush her
she's you know she felt young and to
take care of her at home so that was the
reason I rented it
um so you know the attention is that
she'll buy it she's got the funds to do
that
um but when you know we're not ready to
do that yet okay um
evict the scumbagers
right so
I just what do I do I just get a lawyer
and go to court like how does that work
well it works different in every state
and I don't know the laws in New Jersey
I'm going to be uh I'm going to make an
assumption that they're more difficult
to evict in New Jersey than they are in
Tennessee
in Tennessee uh everything's pretty easy
uh people don't pay we put them out it's
pretty simple uh you you may have to go
through a whole different rigmarole
there than I don't know I don't know
what the what your law do you have a
written lease with these scummy people
yeah okay yes I do okay I went through a
realtor and I have movies ask your
realtor who they you what attorney they
use for evictions
and call that attorney when you get as
soon as you get the name and send them a
copy of the lease and tell them to start
the process uh and tell them what you've
done and as long as you have followed
what the law says on proper notice and
everything in your area then just
proceed with the eviction and don't stop
the process for anything except these
people leaving your home
okay unless the law requires you to
okay so the meaning if they were to pay
me some money don't stop no no don't
don't accept money they need to move
they need to move they have broken trust
and we don't want them there anymore
under any circumstances
even if they bring you 100 current they
need to leave
yes I
I
um sorry I got myself together now I am
you know I'm paying my uh bills on that
home I and I use my emergency fund to
thank the good Lord that I have one and
I'm continuing to use that I'm trying to
prepare just mentally
um for how long I might think I mean
this can't go on for more than a year
can it I have no idea in New Jersey you
need to talk to an attorney and they'll
tell you exactly I can get them out in
21 days in Tennessee
but on Jersey I don't have any idea
okay and so I my guess is it's probably
a three month to a six-month program
there but I really don't know some
states require ridiculous notice and
they require six different kinds of
notices and they require you to do it
certified mail and you have to be able
to do all this stuff so you may have to
start over on the demand letter that you
did because you may may have done it
without good legal advice
um and so but you need to find out
exactly what the process is and don't
miss a day on the process tighten up
that calendar because what people do is
is they they go oh well you've got 30
days and then they wait 40 days to do
the next thing no do it at 31 30 days
and 10 minutes
okay and then yeah right on the wire on
everything and move them out as fast as
you possibly can and
um
because here's your other problem every
day they stay there disrespecting you
there is a day they're more likely to
tear up your house
agreed in addition to this and you're
not going to get any money out of your
dead Beach probably
all you're going to get from this isn't
is a PhD in evictions you're going to
get a degree a new certificate on how to
do evictions you're going to know how to
do it now
in your state so find out what the law
is in Jersey follow the law exactly and
start immediately and don't miss a
deadline hit every every every Milestone
every marker exactly on the head and
move them and push them and move them
and push them and move them and push
them